checklist of number 66 make a growth
plan and resource it properly people
who make plans to grow have a much
greater chance of growing than people
who don't make a growth plan startups
are intended to grow if they are not
growing at a brisk consistent vibrant
pace they are dying that's basically how
the venture community and public markets
eventually look at these things you're
either growing or you're dying if you're
going sideways you're not growing you're
dying
maybe you're in it to fight another day
great your default alive but we're
really looking for growth
and
when you're starting you're telling a
story about future growth when you start
actually ringing the register and have
users signing up now you're selling
performance so you have to know hey am i
selling the promise of my company or the
performance of my company in the early
days you're generally selling the
promise but at some point you get to a
million in revenue and now they're going
to be looking at the performance as well
as the potential and promise of your
business
you know you know and you can make in
your plan a five percent to ten percent
a twenty percent month over month growth
plan and i suggest you do that and then
you should look at what compounding
growth does to a company that's making a
hundred thousand in year one
versus uh and then five percent
compounded growth ten percent pounding
growth and twenty percent
if you're making
but 10k a month these are radically
different scenarios right adding 500
dollars a month versus 2000 doesn't seem
like a lot but go ahead and do
compounding and you'll see why
compounding interest rates and people
will fight for one point or 50 basis
points or 25 basis points on a mortgage
there's a reason compounding uh interest
rates compounded growth rates really do
work and you got to ask yourself when
you make these plans well if i'm trying
to grow 20 where's that 20 growth going
to come from okay 25 of the 20 of growth
is going to come from landing and
expanding okay that means we have to
have great customer success great
customer support so that people will add
people and are we asking people if they
want to add people and do we have that
set up okay well if we're going to
resource that we're resourcing one group
of people oh we want to get 75 from new
customers this year okay 75 from new
customers means we need more sales
people okay and the sales people need
more leads and the sales people turn
over quicker than regular people in the
company so we need for every two sales
people we want to have online we're
gonna need to hire three because one out
of three are gonna leave voluntarily or
unvoluntarily so make a plan and then
benchmark yourself against the plan and
you will be delighted to see how well
things go for you
and again just like this checklist helps
reduce anxiety and keeps people focused
so does a plan okay startup should
always use accrual-based accounting and
that's item number 67 here make sure
you're using accrual-based accounting
not cash-based
you know just like some people will
start a venture-backed startup and make
it an llc and then have to change it to
a c-corp
some people start with cash-based
accounting they sell somebody a two-year
contract they book a hundred thousand
dollars in november then they have
somebody on a monthly contract in
november instead of uh selling them a
hundred thousand over
you know two years in advance they're
just taking 2500 a month right now
and that's coming in on a cash basis so
you you
basically are confusing everybody as to
what's going on have a great accountant
or have a good accountant but have an
accountant and get to accrual based
accounting so that you're booking your
revenue when you actually delivered the
service that's what it means if somebody
buys a year-long membership to a gym the
gym doesn't take all that money in
january they spread out you know the
twelve hundred dollars a hundred dollars
a month right and you book a hundred
dollars every month and the same thing
is true for expenses you can then spread
out expenses if you had to buy i don't
know a forklift
or a tractor at a farm and you're
leasing it well you're paying every
month at least but if you didn't lease
it and you paid cash for it well you
could say well the life of this you know
120 000 tractor is going to be 24 months
and then we're going to sell it and get
half our money back therefore 60k over
24 months equals this amount of money
and we'll spread all those costs and you
can talk to your accounts about how to
do that legitimately
uh and it gives you just a more crisp
view of the business and it builds your
credibility doesn't it so often people
ask me if you're using cash-based
accounting if that eliminates you from
raising venture capital no but they
might say fix this and then we'll fund
so it might delay your fundraising if
you're kind of meandering and you're not
high growth and you have cash-based
accounting those two things combined
might lower your credibility so much
that the vc just invests in somebody
who's got tighter books and a tighter
snapshot of the business when you're
doing cash-based accounting really the
problem becomes you don't understand the
business and we really want to
understand the business and if you can't
understand the business in a crisp clean
way you can't explain it and you got all
this cash problems because you paid your
legal bill that comes up every nine
months and you were behind a year you
paid 75 000 this month and we don't know
what's happening with the business
because it's so spiky
that's that's a big problem for
investors so i really think that that's
the problem is your credibility and the
ability to tell your story and
understand the reality of the business
68 on our checklist are you default
alive and why is that so meaningful paul
graham wrote this in a 2015 essay he
wrote some great essays about startups
uh really just a master of focusing on
what's essential in a startup and then
that comes from investing in he probably
did the first thousand investments or so
in
y combinator and default alive basically
means you're at break even or even
profitable and you've got unlimited
runway you don't need to raise any more
money
and it puts you in the driver's seat of
a founder for many reasons
you only need to raise money
if you want to and if the terms are
great so i in september of 2019 i coined
the term the pegasus startup in a blog
post
and quote i'm quoting myself it's a
little obnoxious a startup is one of
that is so profitable that is able to
use its profits to source so high that
it skips multiple rounds of funding and
i've got a couple of these in my
portfolio com and fitbot are the two
best examples they're both
subscription-based consumer businesses
interesting and trend there
and what it basically means is
you know you don't do these dilutive
rounds so if you skip a 20 dilution
round two or three times my lord you
might have twice as much equity in the
company and that's meaningful uh and
building off profits and being efficient
having low burn culture that means that
those kind of companies when people come
to raise money and they say oh well we
want to have two board seeds or we want
this ratchet or we want these terms or
we want to buy 25 you can say i'm only
raising i'm only selling five percent
take it or leave it i think notion was
the other uh pegasus company they just
skipped multiple rounds of funding as
well and so shout out to sarah cannon uh
for doing the notion round i think they
just raised at a billion dollars like 50
million or something or 2 billion and
they skipped all these uh you know
highly dilutive early rounds and i was
i'm saying that as an early stage
investor and the reason i can say that
with confidence is listen if i only own
five percent of the business or seven
percent of the business i really want on
15. but you don't dilute me 50
in the future rounds well i'm kind of in
the same place aren't i because the
company's worth more yeah i would have
liked to own a higher percentage but it
is what it is right and actually it
offered the fitbot team multiple times
to invest they said they said no to me
we don't need the money jkl we love you
we don't need the money and then finally
i got them to accept a couple of million
bucks at higher and higher evaluations
and then was able to put a little more
money to work but uh you know i'm just
happy to be in business with them and i
love an efficient company and a founder
you know default dead pretty obvious
like you're not making money though you
haven't hit your milestones
you have no more cash or you're running
quickly out of cash and nobody wants to
invest in you you're kind of going to be
default dead you're what we call in the
business of zombie
and so this is why growth is so
important and at some point you need to
know when to wrap it up and just throw
in the towel
concede this match you see it with chess
players you'll see it in poker somebody
folds a hand had a great hand
on the flop but it got really bad on the
river in the turn and they fold it could
be getting bluff there could be a
mistake but whatever you live to fight
another day play another chess match
uh you know sometimes you take the
starters out and you throw in the bench
or you throw in the you know developing
prospects because you're down 30 and you
just want to rest your team and
you know you don't play the fourth
quarter it happens and so
you know uh it's important to know where
you're at and be candid with yourself
if you listen to this week in startups
often you've heard me talk about oh do
suite of business apps a lot well
they're gonna give you your first app
free forever and then a thousand dollars
off your implementation pack at odoo.com
twist odo dot com twist and here's why
odoo is so great for startups well their
suite of business apps can help you run
your entire company from just one
platform they're going to streamline all
your workflows by bringing all your
information together this eliminates all
the annoying repetitive tests like
entering data across multiple platforms
plus if you only need two or three apps
right now that's okay use those two or
three apps to optimize your workflow and
that's all you'll pay for odoo is not
going to charge you for apps you don't
use of course they wouldn't do that so
odoo offers 30 main apps and over 16 000
apps from their open source community
you know the apps they have bookkeeping
sales crm website builders and more
again your first app is free forever and
odu is offering a thousand dollar credit
on your first implementation pack
go to odoo.com
for a thousand dollars off that's
odo.com
twist